localities should be allowed to ban pit
bulls pit bulls commit all the dog
attacks pretty much it's the breed it's
not the individual dogs it's the breed
dogs are not capable of reason the breed
is extremely dangerous it's not the
dog's fault but it's just the way
they're built and the mall little
toddlers and localities are entirely
within their rights to say that they
don't want to have pit bulls there so
DeSantis and the Florida legislators
just passed a law prohibiting localities
from Banning pit bulls localities in
Florida had been Banning pit bulls for a
very long time and then for no reason
whatsoever for no political benefit at
all Rhonda Santos was in the fight of
his life for president and the Florida
GOP go in and they say no you need to
let pit bulls come into your community
and eat your toddlers what the hell is
going on with the DeSantis campaign